The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
I think we're gathered.
So let's get going.
We were going to
DAEs today, but we
decided to postpone for one
day and do a little catch up
on different things
that you should know.
And I thought I'd
first back up a minute
and recall what
you've learned so far.
So we started out talking
a lot about linear algebra
and, particularly, the
problems of this type
where you're given a matrix
and you're given a vector,
and you want to figure
out what the x is
that makes this equation true.
And you've become
extremely familiar
with the convenient
Matlab backslash function.
You've probably used
this a lot of times.
And if you remember, this is one
of the only problems where we
often have a unique solution.
We know a solution exists.
And we can do a
finite number of steps
in order to get the solution.
And actually, the method
we have is really good.
So it almost always
gives us the solution
and to machine accuracy.
So this is a brilliant method.
And so everything is based
on this in our whole field,
actually.
So we learned this first.
We learned it takes
n cubed operations
in order to get
the solution, where
n is the size of the vectors.
And when we do the solution,
the x we get for backslash,
invariably, it
either is a solution,
solves this equation
to machine accuracy,
in the sense that you
multiply m times x,
you get b to as many
digits as you can read.
However, we talked about how
m could be poorly conditioned
so that there might
be multiple x's
that would solve this
equation to machine accuracy.
And so that's the problem
with ill conditioning.
So it's not that it
doesn't solve the equation.
It's that we're not really
sure that's the right x.
You could get a bunch
of different x's that,
basically, solve it as
well as we can tell.
All right, so do you
guys remember this?
All right, and so
that also implies
that if you make a
very small change in b,
you might get a
gigantic change in x.
Because even for one b, you
have a quite a range of x's that
could work, all right.
Then we try to solve
problems like this.
Right, systems of equations,
not just linear ones,
but nonlinear ones as well.
And what we decided to do
as one of our best methods
is Newton-Raphson,
where we keep on doing j
backslash f
[INAUDIBLE] negative f.
Right, so all we did in
this method, a lot of times,
is we just kept on calling this
method over and over again.
All right, so this
took order of n cubes.
This thing is going
to take order of n,
I don't know what you call
it, steps or something.
Maybe if you guys
have a word for it.
What do you call the iterations?
Iterations.
So it takes the number of
iterations times n cubed.
Now, if you really can
make Newton-Raphson work,
and you have a really
great initial guess,
the number of iterations
is really tiny.
Because Newton-Raphson is
such a fantastically great
convergence.
However, we're usually
not such good guessers.
And so it might take
a lot of iterations.
And in fact, we use
the dogleg method
to solve this as we've
discussed about where you mix up
different methods.
And you have a trust region
and all this baloney.
And so it might
actually be quite a lot
of iterations to get there.
And then we went and tried
to solve this problem.
And what we decided to do
for both of these was almost
do the same thing.
So I said, well, we can
really solve this one
by instead solving this.
Right, that's really
what we ended up doing.
That's what happens
inside fsolve is
it converts the
problem of finding
f of x equals 0 into
a minimization problem
to try to make the norm
of f as small as possible.
Because the answer will
be when the norm is zero.
And if f of x equals
0 has a solution,
then the global minimum
here is a solution,
as long as your initial
guess is good enough
that you're in the valley that
leads to the true minimum.
Then this will work.
And that's actually
what fsolve does.
So these two guys get
kind of coupled together,
the minimization problem and
the root-finding problem,
or the problem of
solving systems
of non-linear equations.
And in both of them, we're
going to call the first method
a million times.
OK, so that's the way
we're working so far.
And actually, when
you do fmincon,
which was the next
level, then you actually
end up looking
for saddle points,
which, again, we look
for as minimizing
the norm of a gradient
squared, which gets it back
into this kind of form.
And so they're all
the same thing.
And you can, again,
work out estimates
of how much effort it takes.
And it's something times
n cubed, Typically,
if most your work is this.
Now, I should make a comment
that, in practice, that's
not always true.
So in practice, sometimes,
although the highest order term
is n cubed, the linear
algebra programs that do this
are so great that the
prefactor is tiny.
So in order to get
the limit where
the n cubed term was actually
dominate the CPU time,
you had to have a gigantic n.
And in fact, the limit,
it's often the effort
to construct the matrix j.
And so it really
goes as n squared.
So although this nominally
is like n cubed, in practice,
a lot of times, it's n squared.
And I say it for
these other methods.
And then a lot of
them get into how good
the initial guesses are.
Because the number of
iterations can get crazy.
And in fact, maybe,
it never converges
if your initial guess is bad.
So that can be a
really critical thing.
[INAUDIBLE] is better.
Because you can't
change n I mean,
how many unknowns you've got is
how many unknowns you've got.
But you can change the
number iterations by, say,
more clever initial guessing.
And that was the whole concept
about continuation and homotopy
and all this kind
of stuff was trying
to help reduce this number.
Last time, we talked about
implicitly solving ODEs.
And so we had an update formula.
So we were solving an ODE.
The initial value
problem, y of--
Right, and we said
that, first, we went
through the explicit methods.
And they were perfectly
straightforward to do.
And you don't have to solve any
systems of nonlinear equations
to do them.
And so that was great.
But then we pointed out
that, a lot of times,
they're numerically unstable.
And so then you have to
instead use implicit methods.
But the implicit methods
generally work this way.
They have your new value of y.
What you're trying to compute
is your current value of y
plus delta t sums g.
It depends on the size
of delta t and y new.
Maybe y old also.
And these g's are things like
the Crank-Nicolson, which
you're going to work
on in the homework,
and we show it in class too.
And so there's different
update formulas
of people suggesting
how to do this.
The trick of this is that the
y new is inside the function.
So therefore, this is
really another problem
like we had before.
You can really
rewrite this that way
by just putting this
on the one side.
Put them all on
one side of zero.
And now, I'm trying to
figure out what y new is.
And I'm going to solve
that using this method.
that by using this method.
All right, so now, how is
the scaling going to go?
At each time step, I have
to solve one of these guys.
How much effort did that take?
We did that, right.
Here it is, n [? after ?]
times n squared.
And then how many times
do I have to do it?
AUDIENCE: It's h times
7 times [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Right it depends
on how many times steps
I have [INAUDIBLE] my delta t.
So it's something like t
final minus t 0 over delta t.
That's the number
of times steps.
But I have constant delta t.
Times the number of
iterations that it
takes to do the
nonlinear solve times n
squared, which is a cost of
forming the Jacobian matrix.
Now, this can be pretty large.
So as we talked about,
this might be as big 10
to the eighth in a bad case.
Certainly be less than 10 to
the eighth because otherwise,
you'll have numerical problems.
Maybe, it's really
going to be 10
to the sixth for a real problem.
So you have a
million time steps.
At each times step, you have
to solve the number of iter--
the solve costs this much.
Number of iterations
might be what?
How many iterations
do you guys take
to solve nonlinear equations?
You solve a lot of them now.
How many iterations
does it take?
AUDIENCE: 10.
PROFESSOR: 10, does
that 10 sound right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You've got
an initial guess 10.
If you have a medium
initial guess, maybe 100.
It it's more than 100, you're
not going to converge, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
So this is order of 10 maybe.
So the million 10
and then n squared
just depends on how
big your problem is.
So in my group, the
problems we typically do,
n is approximately 200.
So this is like 200 squared.
And then you can see that the
number of iterations, and this
is maybe a little
bit overestimated.
Maybe I can get away with 10 to
the fifth, something like that.
But you can see it
starts to get pretty big.
But for writing it, as you
guys are writing software,
it's not that big a deal.
So I can assign it as part 1 of
a three-part homework problem.
It's the right ODE solver.
It solves implicit equations.
And you can write it.
And the reason you can is
because you've already written
methods that solve this.
Actually, Matlab did it for you.
But you write it yourself.
I assigned to the
[? 10:10 ?] students.
So you write the
[? backsub ?] solution
to solve the equations.
And we we've already
wrestled this.
And I think you guys wrote
one of these yourself.
And also, we can
use fsolve, which
is just another little
bit better implementation
of the same thing.
And then now, you
write your next level.
So you can see you're doing
a composite process, where
you're doing something
at the top level.
It's calling something
at a lower level.
That's calling something
And then what you really
have to be concerned
about if you're
worried about CPU time
or whether the thing is going
to solve before the homework is
due, is how big does this get.
How many operations
are you really asking
the computer to do?
Now, remember the
computer is fast.
Right, so it can do a
gigahertz or something.
So you can do like 10 to the
eighth somethings per second.
And what should
I say about this?
I have not included,
but I should that it's--
well, I'm assuming here
that the function evaluation
is sort of order n of how
many variables they have.
OK, sometimes,
function evaluations
are much more
difficult than that,
primarily because, sometimes,
they're actually including
further nested stuff inside.
So your f is actually coming
from some really complicated
calculation itself.
And then you have
another big giant factor
of how much it costs to do f.
But on this right here, I'm
just assuming it goes as n.
So actually, let's
just multiply this out.
So this is what, 10 to the
fourth, 10 to the 10th.
So this is 10 to the 10th.
10 to the 10th kind of flops.
But your computer does 4 times
10 to the ninth per second.
Is that right?
Is that [? what they ?]
told us, four gigahertz?
Yeah, so is this really not
bad with just a few seconds
on your computer.
So that's why you can do
these homework problems,
and you still get them done.
And if you have even
[? porous ?] limitations,
it takes 1,000 times longer.
Still, 1,000 [INAUDIBLE] take
20 minutes on your computer.
So you're OK, but you can see
we're starting to get up there.
And it's not that hard to
really make it a big problem
if you do something wrong.
And just a notation thing, a
lot of these things we're doing
are writing software that
takes as input not just numbers
or vectors.
So those are things
that we call functions.
Right, things that take a
number of vectors and input
and give you, say, a function,
a number of vectors and output.
But oftentimes, we actually want
to take the names of functions
as inputs.
So for example, the
root-finding problem,
it takes as input what is f.
Right, you have to tell it the
name of a function for fsolve
to be able to call it.
So fsolve is an object
that takes as input
the name of a function.
And things that do that
are called functionals
So for example, this one is x
is equal to this root-finding
functional, fsolve.
And I'm going to write
with square brackets.
It depends on f.
That's it, right?
[INAUDIBLE] f.
So you give it the function f.
And if fsolve's
good, it should be
able to tell you what the x is.
Now, in reality, we help it out.
So we give it x 0 [? 2 ?]
just give it a better chance.
I write the square brackets just
indicate that one of the things
inside is a function,
not just numbers.
We do this a lot.
So you guys have done
this since you were kids.
So derivatives Yeah, ddx of f.
So we have, I don't know,
for example, grad of f.
That's a functional, the grad.
The symbol means the
operator, the functional,
it operates on functions.
You could write a
general gradient function
that takes any scalar
valued function and computes
the gradients with
respect to the inputs.
This week, we give you one
that computes a Jacobian.
Give it any f of x.
It gives you the Jacobian
of f with respect to x.
So that's a functional.
So anyway, we do a
lot with functionals.
You've been using
them all the time.
I'm just trying get you
to think about abstractly.
And then there's a whole
math about functionals.
And there's a whole thing
called calculus of variations.
It's all about, if the
objects you're worrying about
are functionals, not
functions, then you
have another whole bunch
of theorems and stuff
you can do with that,
which you'll probably
end up doing before you
get out of this place.
But I'm not going to
do that right now.
I would comment that one
kind of functional that's
particularly important to a
lot of people in your research
is the fact that the
energy of any molecule
is a functional of
the electron density.
And this is the basis
of what's called
density functional theory.
And so this is why a lot of
people, you and many of you
included, are going to end up
using computer programs that
are trying to find what the
electron density shape is,
things like molecular
orbitals and stuff.
You've probably
heard these before.
And then there's the
functional that gives
the energy of the molecule.
And what you care about,
mostly, is energy,
because that connects
to all your thermo.
You're doing [? 1040, ?]
it's all about the energies.
And once you know
all the energies,
you can actually
compute the entropies
and all kinds of stuff too.
And so this is one application
that's really important.
It was a little
surprising this was
true and able to be
proven to be true.
And so the guy who did that
got the Nobel Prize-- his name
was Cohen-- a few years ago.
Actually, in liquid
phase stuff, you
work with Professor
Blankschtein.
They also have a version of
this for properties of solution.
And then where it's not
the electron density,
but it's actually the density
of the material in the solution
phase.
Maybe Professor [? Swan ?] too.
You guys do that?
Yeah, so if you work with
Professor [? Swan, ?] you
might learn about that too.
So that's one where
the actual functional
is like a big focus
of the entire project.
And the key is that
this is a function.
The density is a
function of the position.
And then the functional
converts that into a number.
That's all page one here.
Now, I'm going to sort of
change topics, but it's related.
It's about the connections
between numerical integration,
interpolation, and
basis functions.
These things are all
intimately tied up together.
So I'll try to show you.
So we try to solve a
numerical integral.
And then let's look at
what we're really doing.
When we're doing
this, we typically
only do a few
function evaluations.
So we have a few points where
we know the numbers f of tn.
We've picked a few t's.
We evaluated f.
And from those few
points, that small number
of function evaluations, we
want to get a good estimate
of this whole integral.
Now, it's a little
goofy, actually,
if you think about what
we're trying to do.
So suppose you're trying to
do an integral from negative 1
to 1.
We have some function that has
a point here, a point here,
a point here.
And just for concreteness,
let's say this is 1 over 26.
And this is 1.
And this is 1 over 26.
And I have a particular
function in mind
that has those three points.
Now, the first thing
to keep in mind
is there's an infinite
number of functions that
go through those three points.
Now, what we've
been doing is we've
been fitting some
function to these points
and then integrating that
function that we fitted.
So when you're in high school,
you did the rectangle rule
and what the function was
used was this and this.
And you knew the
integral of this function
and the integral
of this function.
And you added them up.
And you decided from
the rectangle rule
that the integral was
equal to 1 and 1/26.
But then some other
people in high school
are a little smarter.
And they said it's not
so smart [INAUDIBLE]..
This thing was
symmetrical to begin with.
And now, I'm fitting
it with a function
that's wildly unsymmetrical.
So let's instead not
evaluate those points.
Let's instead evaluate
the midpoints.
And maybe we find out
that the midpoint values
are here and here.
And so I would assume that the
function is just a flat line.
That looks not so good
either, because it doesn't
get through these points.
But anyway, for the
two points I knew,
if I only used those
two points, that
would be the midpoint method.
And I would get the
I midpoint method.
And I'd get something.
And I did it for this particular
function I have in mind.
And it was 8 over 29.
And then some other
people say, well,
let's use the trapezoid rule.
So let's approximate
the function
is this over the interval,
which looks kind of sensible.
And if you do that,
it turns out you
get the same numbers as you
do with the rectangle rule.
So I trapezoid.
Now, let me just as a warning,
if you just do the rectangle
rule and then the
trapezoid rule,
and you got the same
number both times,
you might be tempted to
conclude you have converged.
And you have the true
solution, because you
did two methods of
really different orders,
and you got exactly
the same number.
And you're super
happy, and you're
ready to publish your paper.
But of course, the function
might not look like this.
So the particular function that
I always had in mind was f of t
is equal to 1 over
1 plus 25 t squared.
OK, that was just the
function I had in mind.
And the way that function
looks like is like that.
And the real integral
of that function,
which you guys if you remember
how do it from high school,
you can actually
evaluate that integral.
It's nothing to do with
either 8/29 or 1 in 126.
It's something
completely different.
Now, those of you who went to
really advanced high schools,
you also learned
Simpson's rule too.
And Simpson's rule says
let's fit it to a parabola.
And so that would give
you something like this.
And if you do Simpson's
rule, I ended up getting this
if I did the arithmetic right.
1 and 1/3 plus 2/78.
Who knew?
OK, which also has
little relation
to the true value
of the integral.
Now, if you're smart, and
you did trapezoid and then I
it to Simpson's, then you
say, oh my goodness, these
are not really that similar.
And so I'm not converged, and
I'd better do something else.
So I just want you
to be aware when
we do these rules, what
we're actually doing
is we're fitting our points
to some continuous function
that we know how to integrate.
And then we do the
analytical integral
of that function, which
is a fine thing to do.
But just be aware that
it's like extrapolation.
It's like we're imagining
what the function is
doing between these points, when
we actually haven't tested it.
Now, we could.
We could just call more points.
We could calculate.
But that would cost us
more function evals.
And we're trying to
save our computer time.
So we want to finish
off before the TG
so we can go buy some beer.
And so we have to take some
choices about what to do.
And we can't do an infinite
number of points for sure.
All right, so in all these
methods, what we're doing
is we're approximating
our true f
with some approximate f, which
is equal to a sum of some basis
functions like this.
So we pick some basis functions.
We know how to integrate.
We fit, somehow determine
what these c's are.
And then we decide
that the integral
is equal to the
integral of f tilde, not
the actual original f.
And then that's actually
going to be the sum
of ck times the integral.
And we carefully
chose basis functions
that we don't how to do
this integral; analytically.
So we just plug
that in, and we just
have to figure out that the
c's are to get this to work.
OK, so that's what
you really did
when you're doing this trapezoid
rule and Simpson's rule,
and all that kind of stuff.
And it's just different
choices of what the basis
functions were that you used.
Now, there's a lot
of choices about how
to do that kind of approximation
to make f tildes that
are sort of like f's with some
limited amount of information.
And it generally has to do
with how many k's we have.
So if k is less than n, then
it's really an approximation.
Because there's no
way that we would
expect that with just
a few parameters,
we could get a lot f of tn.
So we would expect that f tilde
of tn is not equal to f of tn,
at least not at all the points.
Because if n is--
if we have a lot of points and
we only have a few parameters,
we don't expect to be
able to fit it perfectly.
So we know this
is what we expect.
It might happen
if, by some luck,
we chose a basis function
which was actually
the true function f, then it
would actually fit perfectly.
But most of the time, not.
By Murphy's Law, in fact, it's
going to be completely wrong.
But this is not such a bad idea.
We may come back to this later.
Another possibility is
to choose k equals to n.
And then usually, we can force
f tilde of tn to equal f of tn.
So at the points that we have,
if we have enough parameters
equal to the number
of points, then often,
we can get an exact fit.
We can force the function to
go through all the points.
And when we do this, this
is called interpolation.
Now, when should you do
the one or the other?
When should I make
k as big as n?
Or when should I
use k less than n?
A really crucial thing
is whether you really
believe your points.
If you really believe
you know f of tn
to a very, very high number
of significant figures,
then it make sense.
You know that's
true, so you should
force your fitting function
to actually match that.
However, if you get the f of tn,
for example, from an experiment
or from a stochastic simulation
that has some noise in it,
then you might not
really want to do this.
Because you'll be
fitting the noise
in the experiment as well.
And then you might want to use
a smaller number of parameters
to make the fits.
OK, so you can do either one.
You're in charge.
Right, you get the problem.
If somebody tells you,
please give me this integral,
they don't care how you do it.
They just want you to
come back and give them
the true value of the integral
to some significant figures.
So it's up to you to
decide what to do.
So you can decide what to do.
What a lot of people
do in the math world
is this one,
interpolation, where
you're assuming that the f
of tn's are known exactly.
And so your function
evaluating function is great.
And in that case, you can write
down this nice linear equation.
So we're trying to make f
of tn with a true function
to be equal to ck phi n of t.
Sorry, phi k of t.
Which n in [INAUDIBLE]
k is equal to n.
And I can rewrite this this way.
This is like a set of numbers.
So I can write as a vector.
I'll call it y.
And this thing has
two indices on it,
so it looks like a matrix.
So I'll call that m.
And c is my vector of
unknown parameters.
And wow, I know how
to solve this one.
So c is equal to m backslash y.
Now, for this to work and
have a unique solution,
I need m not to be singular.
And what that means is
that the columns of m
have to be linearly independent.
So what are the columns of m?
They are phi k of t1,
phi k of t2, phi k of tn.
And I want that this column is
not a sum of the other columns.
So this is kind of
requirement for j
not equal [? to k ?] This
is kind of a requirement
if I'm going to do
this kind of procedure
is I can't choose a
set of basis functions
that's going to have one of
them be a linear combination
of the other ones.
Because then I'm going
to get a singular matrix.
My whole process is going
to have a big problem
right from the beginning.
So I have to ensure
that this is not true.
Yeah, that this is true.
These are not equal
to some of them.
Another way to write that is to
choose the the columns that phi
to be orthogonal to each other.
And so I can write it this way.
OK, so I want them to be
orthogonal to each other.
And then you can see how
this kind of generalizes.
If I had a lot of t's,
this would sort of
look like the integral of phi k
of t, phi j of t is equal to 0.
And so this gives the idea
of orthogonal functions.
So this is orthogonal functions,
and my discrete point's tn.
And this is the general concept
of orthogonal functions.
And then when I
define it this way,
I need to actually decide my own
a's and b's that I want to use.
And if you use different
ones, you actually
have different
rules about what's
orthogonal to each other.
And also, sometimes,
people are fishy,
and they [? spit ?]
a little w of t
in here just to do, because they
have some special problem where
this w keeps showing
up or something,
and they want to do that.
But that's up to them.
All right, we
won't specify that.
But this is the general idea
of making basis functions
orthogonal to each other.
And it's very
analogous to making
vectors orthogonal
to each other, which
is what we did here.
These are actually vectors.
Right, it's just as the
vector gets longer and longer,
it gets more and more like
the continuous function,
and we have more t points.
And eventually, it
looks like that integral
as you go to infinity.
So anyway, so a lot
of times, people
will choose functions which
are designed to be orthogonal.
And one way to do it is just
to go with a continuous one
to start.
Now, we can choose any
basis functions we want.
Over here, we already
chose a whole bunch.
You guys have done this already.
I don't know if you
knew you were doing it.
But you chose a lot of different
basis functions completely
different from each other.
You can choose the
different ones if you want.
And one popular
choice is polynomials.
But it's not the only choice.
And in fact, a little bit
later, we're going to,
in the homework
problem six, I think
we're going to have
a problem where
you have to use a different
kind of basis functions.
You can use any basis
functions you want.
And there's kind of ones that
match naturally to the problem.
However, people know a
lot about polynomials.
And so they've decided
to use polynomials a lot.
And so that's the
most common choice
for numerical integration
is polynomials.
One thing is polynomials
are super easy to integrate,
because that was the first
thing you learned, right,
how to do the intervals
of polynomials.
And also, they're
easy to evaluate.
It only takes n
operations to evaluate
a polynomial of nth order.
And there's a ton of
theorems, and things
are known about polynomials.
We have all kinds of
special properties.
And we have all kinds
of convenient tools
for handling them.
So let's go with
polynomials for now.
Now, I want to warn you, though,
that how you order polynomials
are really not very
good fitting functions
or interpolating functions
for a lot of problems.
And in particular,
for this one I
showed here where
this is the function.
Here, that function, you can
try to fit that with higher
and higher order polynomials.
So I can have my function.
The function value at 0 is 1.
So the function looks
kind of reasonable.
Like that, symmetrical,
better than I drew it.
And you can put some
number of points in here.
And then you can do an
interpolating polynomial that
goes through all the points.
And if you do it for this
one with five points,
you'll get something
that looks like this.
It goes negative, comes up
like this, goes negative again.
So that's one you
get if you use five
points across this interval.
If you use 10
points, then you get
one that looks like this
where the peak value here
is two where as the max of the
original function's just one.
And the original
function's always positive,
but they both go negative.
So even within the range
of the interpolation,
the polynomials can
have wild swings.
And so this first one was
for a fifth order polynomial,
or maybe fourth
order, five points.
And this one is for the
next 10th order or 9th order
polynomial.
I'm not sure which one.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What points are these
polynomials trying to fit?
Or does it seem
like [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: So I
didn't draw very well.
When you guys go home, do this.
Right, on Matlab it
will take you a minute
to solve this equation where
you put in the function values
here.
And put in the polynomial
values that [INAUDIBLE]
here for the monomials,
t to the first power,
to the second power, to
the third power, like that.
And just do it, and you can
get the [? pot ?] yourself.
And just to convince
yourself about the problem,
and this is very
important to keep in mind.
Because we're so used to
using polynomials that think
they're the solution
to everything.
And Excel does them great.
But it's not this
solution to everything.
Nonetheless, we're going
to plow on and keep
using them for a few minutes.
So one possibility when
I'm choosing this basis set
is I could choose
what are called
monomials, which is phi k is
equal to x to the k minus 1.
And this one is super simple.
And so a lot of
times it satisfies
this orthogonality thing,
which I showed you before.
But it's a really
bad choice usually.
And what it is is
that the matrix
you have to solve for
this interpolation,
if you have evenly-spaced
points and you have x to the k,
it turns out that
this matrix usually
has a condition number
that grows exponentially
with the number of
terms in your basis,
the number of how many
monomials you include.
So condition numbers
that grow exponentially
is really bad idea.
So this is not what people use.
So you might be
tempted to do this,
and maybe you did it
once in your life.
I won't blame you if you did.
But it's not a
really smart idea.
So instead, a lot of
the mathematicians
of the 1700s and
1800s spent a lot
of time worrying about this.
And they'd end up deciding
to use other polynomials that
have people's names on them.
So a guy named
Lagrange, the same guy
who did the multiplier.
He suggested some polynomials.
They're kind of complicated.
They're given in the book.
But what they really are is I'm
taking the monomial basis set,
and I'm making a new basis set.
So I want phi l to be equal
to the sum dlk of phi k,
where this phi k
it the monomials.
So really, you can
choose any d you want.
You're just taking
linear combinations
of the original monomial basis
set to make up polynomials.
And if you cleverly
choose the d,
you can choose it to
have special properties.
So Lagrange gave
a certain choice
of the d that is
brilliant in the sense
that, when you
solve the problem m
times c is equal to y to try to
do your interpolation, it turns
out that the c's you want,
ck, is equal to f of tk.
So you don't have to do any
work to solve what the c's are.
It's just the f values directly.
No chance for condition
numbers, no problems, that's it.
So that's the
Lagrange polynomials.
Now, Newton had
a different idea.
So this is for
Lagrange polynomials.
If you choose a Lagrangian
[? polynomial ?] basis,
then this is it.
And you do a square system.
That's it.
If you choose the Newton, even
he got into this business too.
And he made some polynomials.
And he made ones that
have a special property
that if you solve it--
so he chose a different d.
You still have to do some solve.
You get the solution.
And then you decide that I
don't like that interpretation.
I want to put some
more points in.
I'm going to do a few
more function evaluations.
I'm going to add some more.
So from the first solve, I
have the values of c1, c2, c3,
up to c the number of
points I had initially.
And now, I want to add
one more data point,
or add one more f of tn, one
more function evaluation.
I want to figure out
with c of n plus 1
is, what the next one is.
It turns out that
it's his polynomials.
The values these
c's don't change
when I make this matrix a little
bit bigger by adding one more
y.
And I add one more parameter.
And I make one more
row in the matrix,
one more column in the matrix.
When I do that, it's
a unique property
that none of these
other c's change.
The solution is going to be the
same, except for the n plus one
[? level. ?] So then I can write
a neat, cute little equation
just for the n plus 1 one.
I don't have to mess
with the previous ones.
And so I'm just adding a basis
function that sort of polishes
up my original fit.
So that's a nice property too.
Whereas with the
Lagrange ones, you
have to recompute everything.
And all the c's will change.
Actually, the c's won't change.
I take that back.
You add points.
The c's won't change, but the
actual polynomials will change.
The d will change.
Because the d depends on
the choice of the time
points in a complicated
way in Lagrange.
So now, you start to
think, oh my goodness, I
have all these choices,
I can use Lagrange.
I could use Newton.
I could use monomials.
Maybe, I should go back to bed.
And you think, well,
could someone just
tell me what the best one is?
And I'll just do that one.
I don't need to learn about
all this historical stuff
about development of
polynomial mathematics.
I'd just like you to just
tell me what the answer is.
So Gauss, typically, figured
out what the best on is.
And he said, you know, if
we're going to do integrals,
we'd really like to just
write our integrals this way.
So our approximate value
to be equal to some weight
functions times the function
evaluations at some times.
Right, that's easy to evaluate.
That would be good.
If I pre-computed the weight
functions [? and ?] the times,
then I put any
function f in here,
I could just do this like zip.
It's one dot product of the f
of tn's I'll have the solution.
So I want to do that.
So what's the best possible
choices of the w's and the t's
to make this really be close?
Well, the problem
is that there's
an infinite number of
functions that somebody
might want to integrate.
I can't do them all.
So he said, let's
just find the one that
works for as many monomials as
possible to the highest order,
as far out as I can go.
And it turns out I have nw's.
I have nt's.
So I have two n parameters
that I can fiddle around with.
And so I should get something
like two n's in my polynomials,
maybe 2n minus 1.
So what I want is that
I want to choose this
so that for the monomial
1, and the monomial t,
and the monomial t squared,
that this i is actually
going to be exact.
So what I want is
for the monomial 1,
I want the summation of wn.
My f for the monomial
1 is always 1.
So it's times 1.
I want this to equal
the integral from a
to b of 1dt, which is b minus a.
OK, so that gives me one
equation for the w's.
Then for the next one,
I want the summation wn
times tn to equal the
integral of a to b of t.
dt, which is equal to b squared
over a number 2 minus a squared
over 2 if I did my
calculus correctly.
And so there's another question.
I have another question
for these guys.
And I keep going until I get
enough equations that determine
all the w's and c's.
All right, so I do
it for t squared.
So I can wn tn squared is equal
to [INAUDIBLE] b t squared dt,
and so on, OK.
And so if you do
this process, you
get the weights and
the points to use
that will give you what's called
the Gaussian quadrature rule.
Now, the brilliant thing about
this is that by this setup,
it's going to be exact for
integrating any polynomial up
to order 2n minus 1.
So if I choose
three, here I'll be
able to determine-- if
I choose three points,
I'll have six parameters.
So I'll be able
determine up to the 11--
11th order polynomial
would integrate exactly.
No, that's wrong.
n's only 3.
I have six parameters.
I can't do this.
2 times 3 minus 1, what's that?
5, there we go.
To the fifth order
polynomial integrate exactly,
I'll have an [? error ?]
for sixth order polynomial.
So this is a rule.
So before, if I gave you three
points like here, most of you
probably would use
Simpson's rule.
Fit this to a parabola.
It has three parameters, a,
ax squared plus bx plus c,
right, for a second
order polynomial.
I would fit it.
Then I'd integrate that.
That would be the normal thing
that a lot of people would do.
I don't know if
you would do that.
But a lot of people
would do that.
So that would be that
what you would get.
And what [? error ?]
would you get?
You'd have error that
would be the scale
of the width of the intervals
to the fourth power.
Right, because Simpson's
rule exact up to the cubic.
You guys remember
this from high school?
I don't know if you remember
delta t to the fourth.
Yeah, OK.
So Simpson's rule has an order
of delta t to the fourth.
But Gauss's method has order
of delta t to the sixth.
So this is for three points.
In Gauss's method, you can
extend it to as many points
as you want.
All right, so
that's kind of nice.
You only do three
points, you get
[? error ?] of the sixth order.
So that seems pretty efficient.
So people kept going.
And so the very,
very popular one
use, actually, seven
points for Gauss.
So you'd be able to
get to the n minus 1.
So you'd be exact for 13.
So if you have delta t to
the 14th power as your error,
that's pretty good.
And then what people often do is
they'll add eight more points.
And they make another method
that uses all these points.
It's called
[? Conrad's ?] method.
He made another method
that gives you the best
possible solution if you had the
15 points, given that 7 of them
are already fixed by
the Gauss procedure.
And so you can get the
integral using Gauss's method
and using [? Conrad's ?] method.
So you can compute the i using
Gauss's method, the seven
points, the i with the
[? Conrad ?] method.
I don't know how
to spell his name,
Actually I think it's like this.
15 points.
And then you can take the
difference between these two.
And if these two
are really similar,
then you might think your
integral's pretty good.
Because they're pretty
different methods,
and if they get the same
number, you're good.
And people have done a
lot of numerical studies
in this particular
case, because it's
used a lot in actual practice.
And it turns out
that the [? error ?]
is almost always less than this
quantity to the 3 Gauss power.
So you have an error estimate.
So you do 15
function evaluations.
You get a pretty accurate
value for your integral,
maybe, if you can be fit well
with whatever order polynomial,
13th order polynomial.
13th order polynomial, yeah.
And so any function
that can be fit pretty
well with the 13th
order polynomial,
you should get pretty good
value in the integral.
And you can check by comparing
to the [? Conrad ?] estimate,
which uses a lot more points.
And if two of these guys
give the same number
or pretty close,
then you're pretty
confident that you're good.
And there's even a math proof
about this particular one.
So this is like really
popular, and it's
a lot better than
Simpson's rule,
but it's kind of complicated.
And part of it you
have to recompute
these tn's and wn's for the
kind of problem you have.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you're
using 15 points already,
why not just split
your step size smaller?
And if you did that, how
would the error [INAUDIBLE]
the simplest?
Use a trapezoid.
PROFESSOR: Trapezoid
or Simpson's rule
of something like that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How would
the error with those 15
steps using trapezoid compare
to [? Conrad ?] and Gauss?
PROFESSOR: So we should
probably do the math.
So say we did Simpson's
rule, and we have delta t,
and we divide it
by 15 or something.
Then we can figure
out what this is,
but it's still going to have
the scaling to the fourth power.
So the prefactor
will be really tiny,
because it will be 1/15
to the fourth power.
But the scaling is bad.
So that if I decide that my
integral's not good enough,
and I need to do more points as
I double the number of points
to get better accuracy, my
thing won't improve that much.
Because it's still only going
to use the fourth power,
whereas the Gauss'
one say it's going
use the sixth power if I
only use the three points.
Where we use 15 points,
is going to get scale
to some 16th power or 15th
power or some really high power.
So for doing sequences, the
Gauss' one is a lot better.
However, what people
do is they usually
pre-solve the
system of equations.
Because this system of
equation does not depend.
When you do it
with the monomials,
it doesn't depend what f is.
You can figure out the optimal
t's and w's ahead of time.
And so they [INAUDIBLE]
tables of them
depending on where
you want to go.
People recomputed them, and
then you can get them that way.
Time is running out.
I just want to jump up.
Now, for single integrals,
I didn't have to tell you
and of this.
Because you could have just
solved it with your ODE solver.
So you can just go
to ode15s or ode45,
and you'll get good enough.
It won't be as
efficient as Gaussian.
But who cares.
You still get a good answer.
You can report to your boss.
It'll take you three
minutes to call
it e45 to integrate the
one-dimensional integral.
The real challenge comes with
the multidimensional integrals.
So in a lot of problems, we
have more than one variable
we want to integrate over.
And so if you have an
integral, say, of a
to b from the lower bound
of x to upper bound of x.
So this is dx, dy, f of xy.
This is the kind of
integral that you
might need to do sometimes.
OK, because you might have
two variables that you
want to integrate over.
And so how we do this, the best
way to think about it, I think,
is that f of x is equal
to the integral of l
of x u of x dy f of xy.
And then, if I
knew what that was,
I would evaluate that say
with a Gaussian quadrature
or something.
So I'd say that this i 2d is
approximately equal to the sum
of some weights--
I'll label them x just to remind
you where they came from--
times f of xn.
And I would use, say,
Gaussian quadrature
to figure out what the best
value of the x's and the y's
are to use.
And then I would actually
evaluate this guy
with a quadrature two.
So I'd say f of xk or xn is
equal to the integral from l
of xn to u of xn dy f of xn y.
And so this itself, I would
give it another quadrature.
This is going to be
equal some other weights.
nj f of xn yj.
Is that all right?
And so this is
nested inside this.
So now, I have a double loop.
So if I took me, I
don't know, 15 points,
15 function evaluations to get
a good number for my integral
in one dimension,
then it might take
me 15 squared function
evaluations to get
a pretty good integral for two.
15 might be a little
optimistic, so maybe 100
is more like if you
really want a good number.
So I need 101 dimension, 100 in
the second dimension squared.
Because I subdivided the
integral into six equal pieces,
say.
And then now, so this is OK.
So you can do this.
It's only 10,000
function evaluations.
No problem, you've got a
good gigahertz computer.
Now, in reality,
in a lot of them,
we do have a lot more
dimensions than that.
So in my life, I do a lot of
electronic structure integrals.
We have integrals that are dx 1d
y1 d z1 for the first electron
interacting with a second.
And then something that
I'm trying to integrate.
It depends on, say, the
distance between electron one
and electron two.
OK, so this is
actually six integrals.
And so instead of being
a 2 in the exponent,
this is going to be like
a 6 in the exponent.
So now, this is 10 to the 12th.
That means that just evaluating
one integral this way
might take me 100
seconds if I can evaluate
the functions like that.
But in fact, the functions
I want to evaluate here,
these guys will take
multiple operations
to evaluate the function.
And so this turns
out I can't do.
I can't even do one integral
this way with its six integrals
deep.
And so this is the
general problem
of multidimensional integration.
It's called the curse
of dimensionality.
Each time you add one more
integral, you're nested there.
All of a sudden, the effort
goes up tremendously and more,
a couple of orders
of magnitude more.
And so we'll come back
later in the class
about how to deal
with cases like this
when you have high
dimensionality cases to try
to get better scaling.
Instead of having it
being exponential,
it was really 100 to the n right
now, 100 to the n dimensions.
[? Can we ?] figure out
some better way to do it.
All right, thank you.